amy schumer regina hall and wanda sykes
brought the laughs at the oscars as the
first hosts in three years wow it's been
that long following beyonce's opening
performance trio took uh the stage at
hollywood's dolby theater with the help
from their hype man
[Music]
[Applause]
with their opening monologue where they
acknowledged the controversy with the
show's new format as eight awards were
handed out prior to live cat to the live
telecast plus they also had to insert a
little jab at the fact it was the first
time three women have ever hosted the
show here were some of our favorite
moments
this year the academy hired three women
to host because it's cheaper than hiring
one man
you know we've been dealing with covet
for two years it's been really hard on
people yeah i mean just
look at timothy chalamet
oh god
i don't know it's not good
it's not good you know what
i still smash
okay
wow
wow
as many of you know a decision was made
to present some behind the scene awards
in the first hour
it was a controversial and difficult
decision but you know i think we've
moved on yeah yeah
oh okay
wait a minute look we're all unions yeah
yeah we love i asked come on that's not
our decision well jada what a beautiful
couple we're honoring a lot of couples
here tonight actually
jada and will smith penelope and javier
bardem and maggie and jake gyllenhaal
[Music]
leonardo dicaprio what can i even say
about him
he's done so much to fight climate
change and leave behind a cleaner
greener planet for his girlfriends
because he's older and
and they're younger okay you get it yeah
that was one of my favorite jokes
all right let's go to regina hall she
did a little bit uh so she decided to
use her time at the oscars to play
doctor informing the audience that they
would have to perform some random
emergency covet testing now those random
patients just happen to be some of
hollywood's most eligible bachelors
including bradley cooper simulator
timothy chalamet yeah you get the point
i'm going to start with bradley cooper
timothy chalamet
tyler perry
uh
simulu
and wait um
javier bart dim or you're still with
penelope you know what actually
no
will smith um
you're married but you know what you're
on the list and looks like jada approved
you so you get on
[Applause]
it's going to be a typical quick covert
test you'll come backstage take your
mask off if you have one uh and your
clothes and then i'm going to swap
no it's simple i'm going to swap the
back of your mouth with my tongue and
we're just going to do some other freaky
stuff which i will record
you don't like that
okay you didn't like that bit
i think that was the most it goes on and
on
and uh
i think that was one of the worst skits
of the oscars to be honest i was
cringe-worthy it was okay so my question
to you what did you think of them as
hosts
i thought they were funny like
so
my thing about like hosting an awards
show comedy versus like
comedy comedy give it to me tell me the
truth girls what did you think i feel
like it's different i think the scale of
like if i go to a comedy show the things
that i would laugh at i'm a much harsher
critic right then at an award show i'm
like oh you made you know they did
something that seemed to hit so
therefore that was funny like i thought
they did a good job i enjoyed them i
enjoyed the three of them together i
loved the bit with the costumes in the
beginning all right i'm gonna break this
down don't hate me everybody because i
was watching in details of this
off the top first of all having three
hosts was everyone had a they had to
wait for their lines to give their their
house right
yeah it was just awkward that point
right and then if you're gonna roast
somebody and they were roasting a lot of
people there's a style to it like you
said they missed the mark when you're
roasting it just felt uncomfortable for
me i i just didn't think they had the
the chemistry uh amy schumer i thought
it was really great and one of the
points that i didn't like was amy
schumer had to justify the way she
looked off the top she was degrading the
way that she looked she looked
absolutely amazing she didn't have to
say she's a mom and this is how great do
i look no we're past that now so i wish
they didn't have that joke in there um
so
it was okay it was okay
it is i will say this and i'll i'll give
it the best joke was at the end when she
said i had the vibe changing the five
channels that was the best
all right i missed something
when i was out the vibe's different in
here
fist bump um i you know
it's never i don't think it's an easy
thing to do it's not i think it's a very
very difficult thing to to um keep the
momentum up keep the mood up keep people
laughing
try to move from you know award to a
ward
give people the breathing room after
certain things happen right like as can
happen in a live broadcast
um and also for three people to juggle
that that's what those things together
is a very challenging thing
given all those things i think that they
did a really phenomenal job together
with the three you're using the word
phenomenal
wow it's tough i think we're on the
opposite side
no
i i i wish
okay maybe this is the thing it didn't
roast people as as much as they did i
think they would have done an incredible
job
you just can't if you didn't roast
people as much yeah or you think if they
did the roasts and they were better
if they were like better yeah yeah like
it has to this is that's it they need
this and they missed it every single
time so i don't know every single time
not every single yeah
okay fine i give them five out of 10.
the gyllenhaal one was good yes that was
good yeah okay okay okay i'll give you
credit but i think next time they just
need one or two people i mean i would
love to see tina fey and amy poehlerbach
to do something like that or maybe
bringing chris rock back next year i
don't know maybe i'm just putting it out
there i'm just going to call it right
now i want the ratings i mean it could
work it would do well but okay you know
what three ladies i love it i love it
yeah okay but you wouldn't say
phenomenal
phenomenal's a big word a big word it's
a big